they forgot to tell you man I'm really
happy to be hanging out with you this is
nice
oh man she's been great man I'm same
here man you busy with your show I got
my stuff this is really cool yeah this
thing a black actor's man we need to
just unify we can't just be out like
exactly they wanna win I think you pass
our turn the restaurants back that way
that's all right relax get some we get
some we you know Howard you boy there he
is
break yourself fool
Dave you making me nervous you making me
paint but you go snitch now you're not
gonna snitch right oh no you should I
get its meaning it's Dave it's me estate
you black actor's man we gotta stick
together black come on me baby stage
stage person it's your boy okay
sorry man
I gotta get some money man I gotta go to
ATM I don't have no money
I'll get some more all right right here
where's the ATM eight we at it Oh Dave
Dave hold that's what I like to hear
this oh that's nice thank you
all right more power to me
all right thank you baby Oh Oh we're
killing what's this mr. Franklin's
lonely just really sorry daddy was
meeting some of me sorry daddy
what the hell did is Wayne Brady gonna
have to choke a bitch
[Applause]
try not to be I'm like you know what
like okay you better thank Dave
Chappelle well thank you and I like it
[Applause]
[Music]